So, we have the same goal, which is to create an
awesome pizza application on Android. And now we've ended up with
three feature lists, yours, mine, and yours. So what is the
best set of features to end up in this perfect app?
>> So this is a really common problem
that you as a developer have probably faced
over and over again. You have all these
really great ideas, so which ones are going to go
into your feature list? I can totally see
a lot of people wanting to order the same
thing every time. And I can also see
a lot people wanting to order fresh new things.
So what are our two main options here? What are our solutions?
>> Well, there's two things we could do. One is, we could
actually combine all the features. And end up with an application that
has nine features. So, maybe accommodating
everyone's perspectives into account and or,
or another thing we could do is we could just pick one.
>> Yeah.
>> So basically pick either your or mine or your feature list and
go with that.
>> So these are really both bad options because if you
were to combine one or more of these feature lists, you're
going to kind of have an application that doesn't really please anyone.
When you try to please everyone, you end up pleasing no one.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> And if you were to just pick one application
that maybe would represent you or your how do you know
how many people out there actually have those same attributes?
You could be missing out on a lot of different things.
>> So how do we solve this if both of these are not that good of an option?
>> Well, this is where user-centric design comes in. We
design a product with a specific user in mind. So,
one of the keys to user-centric design is overcoming our
own biases. So what we've experienced here is preference bias,
that our own preferences are really being put directly into
a feature list, and we're not designing for user, we're
just designing for ourselves. So next we're going to learn about
another bias that we really need to be aware of.